mesdames et messieurs bonsoir dans moins
de quatre jours très exactement jeudi un
français sur quatre va se lever tôt le
matin le coeur un peu serré en effet
pour 13 millions de nos jeunes
compatriotes
ce sera la rentrée des classes la fin
définitive dans des vacances une année
nouvelle avec toutes les difficultés
qu'elles comportent tout au long de la
semaine qui vient dominique fleury et
l'équipe d'antenne 2 vous présenterons
des dossiers sur ce trophée scolaire ce
soir nous essayons d'en préciser les
thèmes dominent chaque année à la même
époque on s'interroge sur la rentrée
scolaire les mêmes formules sont
employés que pour la rentrée sociale les
mêmes mots apparaissent
la rentrée sera t-elle chaude froide y
aura-t-il des bavures y aura-t-il des
grèves ou au contraire cette rentrée des
classes sera t-elle sans histoire certes
la mise en place de l'énorme machine
scolaire 12 millions 900 mille élèves
plus de 850 mille salariés professeurs
instituteurs agents de l'éducation se
déroule rarement sans remis des parents
n'ont peut être pas trouvé de place pour
leurs enfants en classe maternelle
parfois l'inscription dans un lycée ou
un collège est un véritable casse tête
l'administration dans ce domaine encore
bien des progrès à faire
sans parler du coût de la rentrée qui
malgré l'allocation spéciale de 400
francs est encore bien trop élevé pour
certaines femmes polémique de la rentrée
contrairement aux syndicats du second
degré qui annonce de licenciements de
maître auxiliaire le ministre confiant
leur est en voie de tous les enseignants
nous verrons bien
concertation aussi entre le syndicat
national des instituteurs et christian
blacks
car ne l'oublions pas cette rentrée est
aussi celle de l'année
en place de la réforme de la formation
les instits à mettre en exergue
également la pièce maîtresse de la
réforme haby le collège unique prolonger
cette année après la 6e et la cinquième
en classe de quatrième une réforme qui
fait son chemin mais dont l'application
est très inégale le soutien pédagogique
appliquée l'an dernier en 6e et 5e s'est
heurtée parfois incertaine difficulté
c'est dans ce domaine que le ministre
semble vouloir orienter ses efforts la
hausse du coût de la rentrée est sans
précédent affirme la confédération
syndicale des familles qui en précise le
shift + 13 % contre 11 % en 1978 et 9%
en 1977
d'après elle ce sont les fournitures
scolaires proprement dite qui ont le
plus augmenté de 15% cette année
concernant la papeterie elle a relevé
des hausses record dans certaines
grandes surfaces + 39 % pour un cahier
de 200 pages et même 120% pour un cahier
de texte signalons que la hausse moyenne
du prix des cahiers constater
officiellement par l'institut national
de la statistique et de traits et demi
pour cent entre juillet 78 et juillet 70
et moi je tente avec mes trois enfants
que je vais arriver à du pur uniquement
pour les fournitures
alors après les mesures du gouvernement
vous allez toucher une tripe allocation
de rentrée scolaire ya eu au total mis
deux enfants plus un complément familial
de 600 bande oui ça n'est pas
négligeable
ce n'est pas négligeable moi je
considère que c'est déjà englouti avec
les fortes augmentations sur la
nourriture sur le logement sur sur le
transport surtout dans la région veut
par la rivière quand on humeur en
banlieue c'est quelque chose qui arrive
à chiffrer énormément moi
personnellement je pense que c'est une
goutte d'eau
c'est très peu de choses par rapport à
ce que moi je vais faire face à peine
avec sa aux fournitures 1
il me restera encore les vêtements
en cours d'année il y aura certainement
encore autre chose à prévoir une
allocation de 400 francs par enfant est
le complément familial à 600 francs
ce n'est pas assez pour compenser
l'amputation du pouvoir d'achat estime
la confédération syndicale du cadre de
cette année la rentrée ne se fera pas
sous le signe des gadgets dans les
cartons nous reviendrons tout au long de
la semaine sur ces différents dossiers
sans oublier le jour de la rentrée jeudi
prochain antenne de midi sera présenté
en direct d'un collège et à cette
occasion nous évoquerons tous les
problèmes qui se posent lors d'une
rentrée des classes au centre
géographique de la france à
saint-amand-montrond marchèrent c'était
aujourd'hui les fêtes du cinquième
centenaire du 1er juin map un prix là
régime français le plus ancien jeu
bourges ministre de la défense a déclaré
quelle que soit la valeur et la capacité
des forces militaires c'est l'adhésion
moral des citoyens qui est l'élément
déterminant de la défense la france doit
à ses armes et d'exister en tant que
nation et les français leur doivent de
vivre libres dans un pays
beethoven wagner et à y mettrons ce soir
un point final à la fête de l'humanité
qui se déroule depuis hier matin dans
l'immense parc de la courneuve de
records battus cette année le parti
communiste à nancy mis la vision
nouvelle et la vente de plus de 600
milles vignette de soutien politiquement
le point fort a été le discours ce
d'après midi de monsieur claude peus
prin l'union à la base est prioritaire
at il dit aux militants communistes
prenez l'union à bras le corps fait dans
votre affaire cet appel à l'union n'a
pas empêché monsieur propre de
renouveler les critiques adressées ces
jours derniers au parti socialiste par
les dirigeants communistes et autres
thèmes de leurs à terre sa politique
d'austérité du gouvernement de monsieur
ban
2 oui mais un oui car il apparaît que
pour les dirigeants socialistes qui ont
pris la responsabilité de l'échec en 78
la seule préoccupation réside dans les
élections présidentielles loi de
sous-estimer celle ci nous vous disons
attendre 1980 s'est laissé le pouvoir et
le grand patronat agir à leur guise et
nous vous mettons en garde contre toute
attente hills
il est de bon ton ces jours-ci de parler
d'échec du plan bas c'est avoir beaucoup
d'illusions sur ce cop peut-être là prit
la politique du président de la
république et de monsieur bart au
contraire nous considérons que la
politique 6/4 diène soutenu sans
défaillance par le rpr en dépit des
discours démagogiques de chirac est une
politique délibérée one man calculer son
objectif est de favoriser
l'accroissement maximum des profits des
grandes sociétés et des banques
le premier ministre quant à lui n'a pas
assez de mots pour s'auto féliciter est
allé son mépris du peuple à l'égard
comme il dit des porteurs de pancartes
et pourtant jamais la rentrée n'a été
aussi dur pour la majorité des français
et des françaises
alors qu'une minorité vit dans le luxe
et que les grands entreprises réalisent
des profits en hausse
quel est le sens que le socialiste est
bien mercredi vous entendrez un thème
2010 notre invité du jour qui sera
monsieur françois mitterrand et qui
viendra nous expliquer en exclusivité ce
qu'est le projet socialiste
les deux obédiences des plus importantes
de la franc maçonnerie française
de tenir leur convainc c'est-à-dire leur
assemblée générale ils ont élu leur
grand maître il s'agit de monsieur
michel de juste pour la grande loge de
france de monsieur je n'aurais pour le
grand orient bonne lefebvre il ya
actuellement quelques 80 mille adhérents
à la franc maçonnerie en france quelle
est sa puissance face à ces onze c'est
une des questions que pose la franc
maçonnerie c'est vraiment une des
questions à quelle les maçons n'aime pas
répondre enfin pour l'instant la franc
maçonnerie je le rappelle est composée
principalement de quatre obédiences
principal dans l'ordre d'importance le
grand orient de france dont le grand
maître michel baroin descendant de
charges n'était pas rééligible nouveau
grand maître vous l'avez dire je leur ai
57 ans est un chef d'entreprise
syndicaliste fo et membre du parti
socialiste
deuxième obédience la grande loge de
france dont le maître sortant dans le
sortant michel de juste 45 de 45 ans et
est rééligible
et là était réel enfin la grande loge
nationale française la moins nombreuses
mais la seule reconnue c'est une longue
histoire par les loge traditionnelle
anglaise à quoi s'ajoute faut pas
l'oublier la grande loge féminine de
france dont l'expansion ces dernières
années est assez significative on veut
dire que la franc maçonnerie vient de
vivre une période comme environnement
troublé
oui je crois après une gamme assez
troublé comme vous dites par des
conflits disons d'orientation politique
encore qu'ils sont défendre les maçons
du grand orient et de la grande loge
avait éludé grands maîtres n'ont pas de
compromis mais d'apaisement les deux
grandes obédiences donc sans doute
chercher à poursuivre ce démarquage des
mondes politique qui menace leur unité
cas les maçons viennent de toutes les de
tous les horizons politiques puis
surtout la franc maçonnerie doit
répondre à deux questions de fond la
première vient de l'extérieur
à quoi sert la franc maçonnerie elle a
été c'est vrai durant des siècles
l'un des rares lieux de rencontres de
liberté d'expression mais aujourd'hui il
ya la presse les syndicats les partis
etc
la franc maçonnerie société élitiste
initiatique donc secrète se voulant
apolitique mais préoccupé des grands
problèmes société at elle encore sa
place dans notre monde et puis la
deuxième question elle vient de
l'intérieur elle est posée par les
jeunes générations de maçon faut-il
réformer la franc maçonnerie et comment
le faire surtout sans briser une
tradition de rites mais aussi de rigueur
intellectuelle qui est sa force al ahram
le sommet des pays dits de m'aligner
doit prendre fin ce soir avec un jour et
demi de retard sur ce qui avait été
prévu les travaux se sont déroulés avec
des hauts et des bas ainsi il ya eu
à limiter pour condamner les accords de
camp david avait traité israël wii u
siens mais dans bien des domaines
il ya eu un désaccord flagrant entre
diverses tendances par exemple celle de
monsieur fidel castro et celle du
maréchal tito bien qu'ici il ait l'air
d'être particulièrement bien sûr
toujours fanny oui on peut même dire
qu'avant cette embrassade entre les deux
hommes il y a eu un match excellent
match a été rude
on peut dire aussi que le champion en
pleine forme qui fidel castro n'a pas
écrasé le vétéran de 87 ans ken leur
échelle didot disons qu'il ya simplement
avantage à castro le leader cubain vous
le savez voulait que les non alignés sa
ligne en fait il s'aligne sur moscou
effectivement ils achètent is factions
en ce sens que la motion finale condamne
beaucoup les etats-unis sans jamais être
dur pour l'urss et pour prendre un
exemple plus précis la conférence de la
havane condamne très durement le
rapprochement israélo égyptien
considérée comme une manoeuvre
américaine
mais la conférence n'a pas pour
l'instant en tout cas exclu l'egypte du
mouvement des non alignés comme beaucoup
de monde et cela c'est tout de même un
point pour les modérés en somme je
répète il y as avantages du camp
socialiste sur les modérés mais il n'y a
pas le cas fidel castro va garder la
présidence du mouvement dans 3 wii et va
sûrement en profiter pour essayer
d'accentuer ce rapprochement entre les
non alignés elle était soviétique
ce qui est évidemment tout à fait en
contradiction avec la position des
fondateurs du mouvement des non alignés
c'est à dire tito nasser et néry in here
ou pour qui non alignement
c'était simplement ne penchait ni d'un
côté ni de l'autre
or aucun des deux superpuissances europe
en fait je crois qu'ils se passent deux
choses en mouvement des non alignés
d'abord que le mouvement étant divisé ce
sont les plus comment dirais-je les plus
extrémistes les plus engagés qui pèse le
plus lourd est certain que la diplomatie
de pays comme le vietnam par exemple de
pays socialistes et plus activistes que
celle de pays plus modérés et puis il se
passe aussi ceux ci qui est tout à fait
fondamental c'est que les non alignés
représente plus de la moitié de la
population mondiale exactement plus de
60% même alors qu'il ne bénéficie que de
15% du produit mondial les pays pauvres
pendant qu raison de dénoncer un ordre
économique injuste et comme les
etats-unis sont la puissance économique
dominante et bien valentin lui ils font
devant les non alignés figure d'accusé
cela dit il faut reconnaître que la
résistance des modérés résistants
symbolisée par ce bloc se concentrait
d'énergie indestructible [ __ ] que cette
résistance a été à la fois élastique et
dure et que le mouvement des non alignés
devant tenir compte s'il ne veut pas
éclaté tunisie le président bourguiba va
bien il annoncé lui même au 10e congrès
du parti socialiste destourien la
carcasse tient bon at il dit et elle se
maintiendra jusqu'au prochain congrès du
parti dans cinq ans monsieur bourguiba
est âgé de 76 ans en tout cas il a
souligné avec éclat que lorsqu'il ne
sera plus là son successeur devrait être
ainsi dit nuire à l'actuelle premier
ministre qui a été lue aujourd'hui par
acclamation et à l'unanimité des
congressistes membre du comité central
du parti socialiste des stocks aux
antilles après le passage de l'ouragan
david quel est exactement le montant des
dégâts
une commission interministérielle se
trouve actuellement en guadeloupe et en
martinique
justement afin d'établir un rapport
chiffré destinée au président de la
république en martinique sé des
bananeraies qui ont été les plus
touchées puisque la production est
détruite à 95% dans ce seul domaine
les dégâts se chiffreraient à 300
millions de francs autrement dit 30
milliards anciens francs ça permet vous
présente les conséquences économiques et
sociales de ce désastre à l'échelon ben
petit village martinique basse-pointe un
petit village de 4000 300 habitants au
bord de l'atlantique dans le nord-est de
la martinique ressource principale
banane et ananas cassé couché par le
cyclone david les plantations sont
détruites ici comme dans toute cette
région nord de l'île à 95%
basse pointe avec ses problèmes
économiques et sociaux engendrés par les
conséquences de l'ouragan représente aux
antilles françaises
l'exemple type du drame que vont vivre
en guadeloupe ou en martinique les
antillais qui travaillait dans les
bananeraies c'est fichu pour de longs
mois et il faut vous dire les
répercussions sociales énormes que ça
aura sur toute cette population de gens
pauvres de gens vivent déjà dans la
misère parce qu'il faut penser que en
période normale
c'est trois ou quatre jours de travail
par semaine que les gens ont sur ce
qu'on appelle ici les habitations
pendant donc de l'an mois on peut
chiffrer sa aux environs de 9 mois les
propriétaires plus pessimistes 6 12 mois
donc pendant toute cette période il n'y
aurait pas de rentrées d'argent dans les
foyers c'est vous dire que ce sera la
misère noire
la mission interministérielle chargée d
évaluer les dégâts du cyclone david et
sur place aux antilles françaises pour
définir les priorités d'indemnisation
les planteurs les plus sinistrés
attendent une aide et des possibilités
d'emprunt pour sauver l'emploi
si l'état ne nous aide pas immédiatement
par des prêts et par des subventions
ces ouvriers qui sont là dans quinze
jours n'auront plus rien à faire
voilà c'est la première chose que n'ont
aucun plan pour de bananes aujourd'hui
ressent la deuxième bien entendu et
qu'il faut redresser cette économie
avant de pouvoir se relancer il faudrait
qu'on en prenne conscience de la
mauvaise état du mauvais état de
l'économie va lanières et qu'on remette
la chose je les rails afin de pouvoir
continuer et puis qu'on aide également
ceux qui à cause de cette mauvaise
économie était déjà en mauvais état
c'est à dire devait déjà beaucoup
d'argent voilà ce que l'on implanté en
ressent aujourd'hui et je vous assure ça
me fait d'autant plus de peine que
depuis déjà sept générations
nous travaillons ici avec les parents de
ces gens qui sont avec nous et que nous
voulions nous voulons continuer avec eux
continuez c'est le mot clé en guadeloupe
ou en martinique
continuer car ici il n'y a que cela à
faire aucune reconversion des possibles
pour les planteurs comme pour leurs
ouvriers
comment vous allez vous en sortir je ne
sais pas qu'est ce que vous attendez
quand vous aident à et elle ne s'est pas
du tout du tout ce que vous êtes anxieux
pour l'avenir
c'est quoi inquiet ah oui tu sais d'où
du c'est très doux
la situation inquiète les élus locaux
qui ne savent pas très bien quelle
tournure vont prendre les événements
déshéritées vivent dans ces cases à
travailleurs comme on les surnomme ici
ces familles ont aujourd'hui perdu leur
emploi alors que les maires de certaines
localités essayé de les sortir de leur
condition en rénovant par exemple
l'habitant ce sont les gens qui sont là
depuis 150 ans depuis l'abolition de
l'esclavagé l'arrivée des premiers
hindoue ce sont des cases qui ne peuvent
plus résister ni au séisme ni aux
cyclones les gens vivent dans des
conditions infecte
il ne leur est pas permis de réparer et
les propriétaires non plus ne tiennent
pas réparer parce que ce sont des gens
qui sont devenus on dirait un peu gênant
le sorte que c'est à tout cela que nous
pensons pour pouvoir les reloger et il
faudrait que nous soyons aidé par le
ministère des affaires sociales et
divers ministères pour pouvoir réaliser
ce plan d'équipement qui je le reconnais
est ambitieux à l'échelon communal mais
aux grands maux il faut employer les
grands moyens dans quelques jours quand
l'école recommencera à basse-pointe les
enfants reparlerons de ce cyclo en
attendant de vivre un jour sur cèze il
le prochain jean seberg et mortelle
s'est vraisemblablement donner la mort
elle-même sans corps a été retrouvé dans
sa voiture stationnée depuis quelques
jours dans une rue du 16e s'est
enveloppé dans une couverture et l'avs
est absorbé une dose massive de
barbituriques
jean seberg était américaine mais elle
vivait la plupart du temps en france
parmi les films qui ont fait son succès
il ya eu la jeanne d'arc d'otto
preminger
à bout de souffle de godard et bonjour
tristesse d'après le roman de françoise
sagan souvent sujettes à la dépression
nerveuse
jean seberg ne s'était jamais remise
d'avoir perdu un enfant de la naissance
était pleine de talent de prims aux
charmantes dans l'existence de tous les
jours mais toute sa vie elle avait
cherché quelque chose qu'elle n'était
jamais parvenu à trouver vraiment c'est
une grande perte pour le cinéma
demain notre émission question de temps
présenté jean pierre elkabbach et martin
à la réunion aura pour thème la santé à
la conquête des organes artificiels
invité d'honneur monsieur jacques attali
hauteur de l'ordre cannibale un livre
sur l'histoire des rapports entre la
maladie l'argent et la société et qui
soulève une série de questions
embarrassantes sur l'avenir de la
maladie et des systèmes de santé tels
que ceux ci points des rays s'inscrivent
dans nos sociétés de consommation
on peut aller jusqu'à se demander est ce
la mort de la médecine et les médecins
question de temps présent pris un film
sur la médecine d'hyères et sur les
organes artificiels demain puis jacques
attali répondra à ces divers
interrogations en compagnie du
professeur américain pierre galletti
spécialiste incontesté des organes
artificiels et le professeur
jean-charles sonia directeur général de
la santé dès ce soir le professeur
pierre galletti l'université brown à
providence rhode island états unis est
avec nous mais sur le professeur on a
l'impression que nous vivons dans une
époque où l'on peut changer de pièce
dans le corps humain exactement par une
voiture
on branche des reins en grève des coeurs
alors pour les deux ou trois prochaines
années qu'elles sont des prochains
organes artificiels que vous prévoyez je
pense que pour les prochaines années
nous verrons
l'application clinique du coeur
artificiel et d'une prochaine révision
est ce que l'on peut imaginer qu'un jour
on puisse entièrement changé l'homme je
veux dire tous les organes ont pu faire
on peut faire certainement beaucoup de
choses on peut remplacer tous les
éléments du squelette les eaux les temps
dans les extrémités des membres
on peut remplacer les vaisseaux on peut
remplacer le coeur ses composantes
on peut même peut-être remplacer les
organes sensoriels mais je doute qu'on
puisse jamais remplacer le cerveau vous
en doutez c'est à dire que vous répondez
par annie get je réponds par la négative
je suppose que tout cela coûtera très
cher
deux questions à ce propos est ce que
cela vaut la peine de dépenser autant
d'argent pour la recherche
et est ce que finalement le monde a les
moyens les moyens financiers d'une telle
politique de remplacement ça coûte
certainement très cher mais dans le
bilan des coûts il faut aussi faire la
part de la réhabilitation des malades à
qui une vie nouvelle est permise par ses
protège est ce que le monde peut se le
permettre certainement au départ les
sociétés les plus avancés auront un
avantage sur les autres vous enseigné
dans une université américaine
quel est le budget des états unis dans
ce domaine pour prendre un seul exemple
cinquante mille personnes sont
maintenues en vie aux etats-unis par ron
artificielle et le coût est de l'ordre
de 6 millions de nouveaux fronts la
multiplication de de toutes les
réussites dans ce domaine
va-t-elle provoquer à votre avis je veux
réussir une révolution médicale
au fond je pense que cette révolution
déjà avec nous petit à petit elle s'est
insinué parce que ces prothèses sont
entrés dans des domaines très différents
de la médecine verres de contact dans
leurs technologies les prothèses
d'orange en orthopédie les prothèses
vasculaires en chirurgie cardio
vasculaire
toutes ces choses sont venus sans être
concertés l'une avec l'autre elles
représentent des jeunes part importante
des coûts médicaux
vous nous avez mis l'eau à la bouche et
ne vous attendons donc demain 20h35
aussitôt après laurent télévisée pour
l'émission question de temps missy jouer
aux courses de longchamp voyez on ne
peut pas toujours faire de transition
c'était aujourd'hui une sorte de
répétition générale pour le prochain
prix de l'arc de triomphe le prix niel
pour poulains de 3 ans a été gagné par
le marmot le prix foy pour chevaux d'âge
a été remporté par pébéreau var l'une et
l'autre course des favoris ont donc été
battu qu'en valognes sommes le grand
handicap tiercé il a permis de se rendre
compte une fois de plus quel grand
jockey est yves saint martin
car il est venu au bon moment mis trop
tôt ni trop tard voyez plutôt dans le
dernier tournant les 25 chevaux qui
dispute le tiercé forme d'un feuilleton
très complet très groupée emmené depuis
le départ par bridges and roll et
pontini les plus petits poids de la
course
dans la foulée vienne laricio atwood qui
folle et bleu nuit marion fait son
effort à l'extérieur avec maysir qui va
très facilement pour aborder la ligne
droite mais il est maintenant devant
avec art lunda petite chaise maçons qui
se rapproche très très vite en dehors
regardez bien j'ai petit casaque verte
que blanche au milieu du peloton
il va faire un instant illusion il vient
comme un bolide attaqué machito de
chaises maçons mais celui ci sur sa
lancée ne cèdera pas
il c'est martin qui est monté avec
masson millimètre près passez le poteau
en vainqueur vous allez voir encore un
succès pour l'entraîneur robert collet
deuxième match et autres chaises malgré
ses 16 ans est lui 3e g steve snyder qui
sera monté la porte soit 21 cents un
très jolie percée qui rapportent dans
l'ordre pour 5 francs quinze mille 625
francs et dans le désordre pour 500 3125
francs
robert charlebois va retrouver par il
chante à partir du 15 septembre au
palais des congrès et paris va retrouver
à charlebois un peu changé par rapport à
son dernier récital et à conserver sa
bonne mine son langage son dynamisme son
humour ce thème de ses expressions
favorites mais en revenant au rock il
teinte son répertoire
son style dirais-je d'une touche
d'agressivité qui n'est pas sans intérêt
en avant-première george v go lui ai
demandé de chanter pour vous une de ses
nouvelles chansons
elle s'adresse à un ennemi intime
votre machine empoché près c'est que ma
tâche et comme cet hiver mardi
que d'amour ou nouveau choc puisse
l'échec et l'oscar fois je touche de
bleu pâle mange comment
charlebois l'impression que vous avez un
répertoire beaucoup plus musclé cette
année ce lit ouais c'est mon jogging
j'ai découvert le djia gagne à une coupe
deux mois avant je me marrais quand je
voyais des gens faire leur jogging
maintenant je vais rencontrer oxygène
bien le cerveau que ça me donne un
second souffle
puis c'est un retour au rock dont je
m'ennuyais un peu il fallait que je
menais 4 mais j'y reviens avec d'autant
plus de plaisir dans le bureau cameron
est encore de l'entraînement à paris où
est ce que le l'atmosphère est bonne
aussi bonne qu'à montréal et sissy c'est
moi
je peux pas me plaindre jusqu'à
maintenant je pense que toutes les
vibrations sont positifs j'ai une équipe
extraordinaire sur tous les plans les
musiciens étaient régis et techniciens
les attachés de presse je suis les
décorateurs aussi entièrement entre les
québécois vous devenez envahissent on en
voit beaucoup beaucoup à paris depuis
quelques années ça commence on se
demande qui va beaucoup nombre de cinq
ou six qui sont heureusement de très
bonne qualité je crois que c'est comme
dirait trudeau l'intensification des
échanges culturels entre les deux pays
entre eh bien vous savez la leçon je
crois que c'est resserrement des liens
qui est assez sympathique
moi je ne vois comme ça il faut
s'attendre à des nouveautés
extraordinaire dans le tour de chant
away absolument plus capable de menacer
plus qu'à matin
oh
très bon dit bruno tibet ce marin haute
et des bonnes idées pour sauver ma
d'harmonie mode saas ionique moins
coûteux 10 mois dopés tonique mode
cochonnet soient plafonnées moustache
marc étienne wolf est tombé musical
aussi des choses la vie qui modérait
launay immo continue
le temps pour demain des passages
nuageux alterneront avec des éclaircies
sur le nord-ouest du pays
sur les régions méditerranéennes et sur
les alpes il fera beau et chaud dans le
reste de la france le temps sera lourd
des nuages seront abondants et des
sondés ou des orages pourront se
produire ce soir vers 23h apps et
bernard pradines au qui a rendez vous
avec vous pour vous présenter dernières
informations demain antenne de musique
sera présentée par patrick lecocq et
vous retrouverez à 20 heures comme
chaque semaine et pour toute la semaine
patrick part modale bonsoir